the White House now says it supports the
direction the sanctions bill is headed
but won't weigh in conclusively until
it's finalized but the message yesterday
from the president's communications team
was muddled new communications director
that's Anthony's car Moochie says he
quote hopes to create a more positive
mojo with the press but a stumble during
his debut shows the challenge that
scared Moochie faces Margaret Brennan is
at the White House with the latest on
this Margaret good morning good morning
well president Trump believes he has a
communications problem and not a
political one he wants his new staff to
change the focus away from his stalled
attempt to overhaul health care his
dismal approval ratings and that ongoing
Russia probe we're gonna work very hard
to change the culture president Trump's
new communications director says he has
one goal we're gonna focus and refine
the messaging from the from the White
House but scaramouche II muddled the
message when he confirmed the president
is exploring the quote complete power to
pardon anyone swept up in the Russia
investigation I'm in the Oval Office or
the president last week we're talking
about that he says he brought that up he
says but he doesn't have to be pardoned
there's nobody around him that has to be
pardoned those comments directly
contradict statements from the
president's personal lawyer pardons have
not been discussed and pardons are not
on the table mr. Trump personally chose
scar Moochie a former TV commentator and
wall street ambassador to reshape his
media image and cut down on damaging
leaks from his own staff where as strong
as our weakest leak so if you guys want
to keep leaking why don't you guys all
get together and make a decision as a
team that you're gonna stop believe me
but if you're gonna keep leaking I'm
gonna fire everybody scaramouche's
sudden ascent was a surprise he did not
initially support candidate Trump even
campaigning against him in this 2015 Fox
News interview the politicians don't
want to go at Trump because he's got a
big mouth he apologized for those words
Friday from the White House podium mr.
president if you're listening I
personally apologize while President
Trump is confident that scarra Moochie
will be an effective advocate his
appointment led press secretary Sean
Spicer to resign I'm leaving it in
capable hands with
Anthony and Sarah Sanders they both
publicly claimed there were no hard
feelings and I love the guy and I wish
him well and I hope he goes on to make a
tremendous amount of money
Sarah Huckabee Sanders will be replacing
Sean Spicer at the podium as the new
White House press secretary and Jeff we
will be hearing from President Trump
later today when he is scheduled to talk
about his latest attempt to overhaul
health care Margaret Brennan thank you
very much